Prime Minister red Jeff tie up our
Dhawan presented his new cabinet 10 of
26 ministers are new all lest allies the
reshuffle comes during the biggest
challenge yet to the premiers 11-year
grip on power police have launched a
major money laundering and bribery probe
against high-level officials and
businessman including the head of
state-run halkbank Suleyman Aslan as
well as former ministers son's air
Dhawan believes the investigation is
orchestrated by Fethullah Gulen his
archrival the Muslim cleric lives in the
US but remains a major force in Turkey
Sean water though a foundation we have
two choices either edwin's AK Party or
Fethullah gülen's movement but we want a
third choice we know that a power
struggle going on that we don't want to
be part of it aire de juan has depicted
the inquiry as a plot against him he's
already purged more than two dozen high
ranking police officials involved in the
investigation he says the Gulen movement
has infiltrated the police and the
Judiciary imbue the reason our party has
been successful and has been ruling the
country for 11 years is our honesty our
commitment to the country and our
determination to fight against
corruption the AK party does not
overlook or tolerate corruption if it
did it would lose its reason to exist
these demonstrators seen matters
differently the scandal has reignited
anti-government street protests popular
support for erawan is eroding